hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about
grammar and my fear of grammar and how i
deal with it
all right so i've been studying arabic
and by the way at the end of this video
i'm going to uh give you a brief sort of
overview of what i do on my ipad or for
that matter on the iphone
when i'm learning
arabic with link
i can do more or less the same things on
the computer
um but fear of grammar okay why do i say
fear of grammar because
as i'm studying arabic
i come across different forms of verbs
different endings
sometimes i'm sort of curious about how
arabic verbs work
so i consult one of the books that i
bought on arabic
i haven't gotten very far into these
books because
of course they're written
you know the content items are in arabic
and i find it very difficult to read
arabic without the
audio the text to speech or the live
audio that we have at link because it's
so difficult to
to guess you know what the vowels are
how the words are pronounced just based
on the letters not to mention the fact
that i still confuse the letters and i
think it's a
zeb when it's a the or i think it's a
duh and it's a r and all this kind of
stuff takes a while to get used to the
writing system so
but i do occasionally want to go to the
grammar book and say okay what's the
explanation of what's happening then i
go there and i'm confronted with the
fact that there are however many types
of verbs in arabic and all kinds of
explanation
that i know from experience i won't be
able to remember
and it it throws up a wall of confusion
and i retreat
so therefore i have this fear i don't
want to get into something where i'm
basically beating my head against a
brick wall and not really learning or
not
retaining anything you know that's going
to be useful to me
so i go back to my arabic go back to
what i'm doing
where i'm able to read
i'm able to understand when i read i'm
able to understand what i hear i'm
gaining more and more experience with
the language
so i'm observing the language now
you do need some grammar
concept you need to be aware of what's a
verb what's a noun what's an adjective
you know uh but many of the things that
happen in the language i'm able to
observe
without having to have it explained to
me without having to
try to remember
explanations i know
uh the word order because i've now seen
so many words and phrases and you'll see
in the overview of how i study that i
say words and phrases i save them as i'm
reading i
tend to go through the lesson sentence
by sentence and then i'll save a word
and a phrase and then i review them
and later on which i don't show you i
can review them in a sort of srs
field if i want so i'm constantly
reviewing words and phrases i'm seeing
the language live in front of me i'm
observing how the language works i'm
observing how concepts are expressed
word order how questions are asked how
adjectives and adverbs behave
and at some point
when i've had enough
of this observing
then i will go and read the explanations
and that'll probably
move my understanding of arabic grammar
you know along
but every time i go there at least at
this stage and i encounter these
theoretical explanations about the
language
about some things that i have already
observed about some things that it's
it's just too difficult for me to relate
the explanation to anything
and i withdraw and i come back to my
observing of the language so my
recommendation and this was my
you know when i first started learning
russian i did it primarily to prove that
to learn a language even a language with
complicated grammar like russian and
arabic has complicated grammar that we
can go a long way without having to
confront the rules and the explanations
and the exceptions we can go a long way
just by observing
and listening reading getting used to
the language and at some point and
certainly more than once
uh later on we can go back in there for
some
explanations but it shouldn't
the sort of upfront grammar explanations
shouldn't prevent us
from enjoying the language and i am
certainly not allowing it to in to you
know
disrupt my enjoyment of arabic where i
feel that i'm making fairly good
progress thank you for listening
bye
so here you can sort of look over my
shoulder
as i work on my ipad
bear in mind that the sentence view
is not yet available on the ipad for the
general user i have a beta version it is
available on the website
the browser version where you go down
and in the settings you can set your
lesson page into different formats
but it will very soon be available uh
for everyone
uh but i just want to use this to
demonstrate how i
mine if you want how i
uh use the text to observe grammar
rather than trying to study it up front
just thought i would give you a
view over my shoulder
bye for now
uber
be
foreign
a
[Music]
you